hey what's up guys my name is Jonah
welcome to episode 4 of game programming
hey guys the last time we took a look at
actually creating like a game loop with
our running variable and a while loop in
our run method and this time you know
today on today's episode we're gonna
take a look at actually making a window
so what I want to do is actually get
something up and running so that you
guys can umm contest this card and see
if it works and check if you got errors
obviously you know we don't because
there's like 30 lines of code here and
not much can actually gon go wrong but
nevertheless we will we will make that
window so first thing I want to do is
make a variable rather an object we're
gonna make a cherry mob check so private
jframe jframe and what a J frame is and
we'll have to import that
a dry frame is basically like a window
okay
it's like frame you could use a normal
frame that's absolutely fine but um
learn easy a frame just because well I'd
recommend you use the Trey frame now one
other thing we actually have to do is we
have to make sure that our game class
extends canvas now what a lesson for
cars as well what canvas is is
essentially what a canvas is is it's
almost like think of it as a canvas like
honestly you're painting in you've got
this canvas it's it's like a it
basically it represents a blank
rectangular area of the screen onto
which you know our application can draw
or arm or also to process input events
so when we press something on the
keyboard as long as we've got a canvas
you know we can process those events we
can actually draw things to that canvas
it's like a blank rectangle on the
screen that we can actually manipulate
in anywhere we want
okay now by extending canvas I'm saying
that the game is a subclass of cannabis
in other words game almost inherits
everything that canvas has again there
are obviously complications to that but
loosely you know what we're saying is
that game is now a subclass of canvas so
with that in mind we're going to
actually create a constructor for our
game class now this is important for
those of you who don't understand a
constructor we're going to do by simply
- having public game and then on our
curly brackets so you can see there's no
return type right I didn't actually
explain this last time because I thought
it was fairly simple but you'll notice
that we're actually typing you know the
visibility and then void right all this
is void
now what void means is that the return
type is void we're returning void we're
returning nothing what we're doing is
we're just executing this code and then
that's it
the method is done we're not actually
returning anything we could have a
method where we return something so in
other words when we call this method it
it actually returns data to us this
returns void this returns nothing it
just completes what's in the curly
brackets and that's it now that is all
you need to know for now
if you're unfamiliar with Java that's it
we're just gonna be using void methods
until things get more complicated so for
now all you need to know is that void
returns nothing if if a method is void
it just executes everything that's
inside the method and that's it it's
done now here we don't have a return
type because this is a constructor so
what we've got instead is just public
and then the name of our class which is
game followed by the two curly brackets
what I call is two round brackets two
parenthesis I don't know - um normal
brackets I guess and then and then we've
got our um curly brackets so the
constructor basically runs where
whenever a new instance of this object
is created so whenever we type something
along the lines of you know for example
again I'm just typing code to prove to
you guys I'm just I'm not gonna I'm
gonna erase this in a second so don't
type this um if I do something like a
new game essentially what's gonna happen
is apart from creating a new instance of
this game it's actually gonna execute
everything that's in this game
constructor so in other words by going
you know throughout equals new thread
same thing if thread has a constructor
which of course it does because we're
taking parameters then when we call that
it will actually execute all the code
that is in the constructor now this is
very useful not going to go into these
forms of constructors of course they're
useful but one of the reasons they're
useful is because this code will only be
run once that is when you create the
object that's very important so whatever
code we create here will only be
actually executed once and that is when
we create this object and game will only
be able to will only be created once as
it should be because we only want to
create one game class not true or
multiple just one so when we first start
our game this is what's gonna happen now
a few things here have to happen first
thing I want to do though is actually
define a size for our game so we've got
three variables here that deal with the
resolution now I'm gonna actually put
them to use and apply these variables to
a method or to a function to actually
you know get it to set our window to
that size so I'm gonna do is type
dimension size all right so dimension is
class it essentially holds a dimension
or
resolution when I set that equal I'm
just named it size because it's gonna be
out the size of our window
the size of our frame equals new new
dimension and then for the parameters
we're just gonna put width times scale
, that's the first parameter and then
second parameter is height time scale so
what we've got here is let's first of
all import dimension now we've got it in
our import list Java now knows what
class were referring to
so with it's gonna be the width times
the scale because remember we're making
um everything three times bigger than it
is here um you'll you'll see the effect
of this in the future I find it really
hard to sort of explained to you guys
exactly what it means so in the future
you'll actually see it in action I can
actually provide you with examples as to
what's going on with a scale and
everything but the window is gonna be
900 pixels wide right with some scale
and the height of the frames gonna be
that right but we've basically just
created a dimension object called size
with essentially with these parameters
so now we actually have to apply it and
the way we do that is we simply type set
preferred size and then the brown resize
so we're setting the preferred size of
our window to this okay that's what
we're doing now for all you guys who are
familiar with this you might be like
whoa set set preferred size that's
referring to a method right where is
this method well essentially where this
method is is it's in cannabis so you'll
notice that that actually if you just
choose hold it up if you just hold your
mouse over it'll tell you but
essentially because we're extending
canvas that means that we got direct
access to its methods that are either
protected or public so in other words
this method is located in canvas or
actually you'll find that it's look at
it in component so I component canvas
extends component and someone's kind of
complicated all you do know is that if
we are extending canvas we can call the
set preferred size method and it will
actually set the preferred size of our
canvas to-to be on the side of this
alright
so that's um that's what I like the
first part of this episode I'm gonna
wrap this up today though but tomorrow
we alum will definitely draw our our
window and you know what scrapped out I
feel like I haven't done anything like
we've literally not we're gonna keep
going so what I want to do now is
actually make a main method so public
static void main and then string and
I'll supply us a minute for those of you
who are unfamiliar for those of you who
you know we tell you what what this
means just chill out and you know take a
break I mean just do something else
while I explain this because some of you
guys are clueless
so public static void main and then
string and then ogz this is essentially
Java's main method so all you need to
know about this is when we when we run
this program it's gonna find this method
and it's gonna execute it here so in
other words this is where our program
starts this is the entry point this is
what happens when we run our program
everything that is in here this is how
our program starts this is our game
starts whatever this is the start this
is the beginning this is the genesis
this is the inception whatever so first
thing i want to do is actually create a
an object out of our current game now
you'll notice that this method is static
that means that in in other words what
that essentially means is that it has no
relation with the rest of our with the
rest of our class so we can't simply
unless we also make variable static we
can't directly access them so well the
first thing we need to do is actually
create an object out of this game class
so I'm going to do that as I would with
any other objects input type game game
equals new game so now we've got an
object of game with with its own
instance right this thing that we can
actually use for the remainder of you
know our programming in this method what
I want to do now is actually also Forge
a frame right I'm actually going to set
frame equal to new jframe so when we
were on this constructor it's going to
say it's going to give a value it's
going to actually set frame equal to new
jframe
creates a new instance of our jframe so
what we can do now is because you know I
guess our frame object is outside of our
static method we can refer to it through
game right because this is remember this
is game this is a game object game dot
frame
dot whatever you know we want to do so
first thing we want to do is actually
set resizable to false so we don't want
our window to be able to be resized that
causes tons of graphical errors let me
tell you and make sure that this is the
very first thing that gets applied to
frame okay so your first thing for frame
should be cetera seizable false if you
plan on doing that and then we do next
thing we'll do is just probably create a
title so set title we'll just call it
rain so you just put a string in here
all right I've just typed rain in
quotation marks that will be the title
of our window so in other words this
window was titled you know Java blah
blah and our window will be called rain
because that's the name of our game
the next thing older is actually I'll
add alright our game component so I'll
add a component to the frame and it will
begin now there isn't this works first
of all is this add method what it does
is you know essentially it just adds a
component into our frame so it fills the
window with something now what we're
adding into it is an instance of this
game object so in an instance of this
class and the reason we can actually add
this class true to our frame is because
our class extends canvas so it's a
subtype of canvas it is a subclass of
canvas so in other words it is a
component and we're adding the component
to our window
next next will actually pack the frame
what pack does is it sets the size of
the frame according to the components so
we've set the size of our component to
be 900 pixels by you know whatever that
is times 3 so we've set a particular
size a particular resolution to our
component to our game pack is going to
basically size up this frame to be the
same size as that component game dot
frame dot set default close operation to
jframe dot exit on first what this is
gonna do is when we actually hit the the
close button in the top right corner or
you know if you're on Mac in the top
left corner if you hit that button it's
gonna jframe dioxide on close so in
other words it's going to terminate the
application when you hit that button
it's going to completely close it's
going to close the process it's going to
end the application when you hit the X
button when you hit the exit button so
that's really important because what can
happen is if you simply close if you
don't have this card and you simply
close your program by hitting the X
button what's gonna happen is it's gonna
keep on running it's just not going to
display the window you've closed the
window but you haven't actually closed
the program so what you want to do is
actually close the program you want to
delete that thread you want to remove
that
sorry not thread you want to delete that
process you want to actually remove that
process that is currently up you know
that's currently running be
we want to close our application when we
if the X button now the next thing we
need to do is set a location so we want
to set the location relative to and we
can actually just put knowledge the
parameter and what that's going to do is
Center our window into the screen so
instead of being in the top left corner
our our frame our window will actually
be right in the center of the screen and
finally game don't frame dots said
visible to true very important make sure
you don't forget this last line of code
because what this is gonna do is
actually show our frame it's gonna show
our window we want to show our window we
don't want it to rain to remain hidden
so make sure it's actually showing by
setting visible to true last thing we
actually have to do is start our game so
we've we've created a window we've done
everything but remember in order for I
came to function we actually need to
call the start method so we can do that
simply by typing game so we're referring
to again the game class
and we'll type game dot star what that's
gonna do is start our game now one more
thing before we actually launch this it
is a serializable class because it
extends canvas so make sure you just add
the default serial version ID okay it um
you don't need to understand a whole lot
about it just add it you know you the
warning will go away it's fine it's
optional it's up to you but um it is a
convention of Java so I suggest you
follow it yeah so in other words let's
just display something in our while
running loop right now so that we can
test if this works so if my system dot
out dot print line what we can do in
here is actually print a line of text or
numbers or anything really and it will
actually print to the console so let's
just print something like running so
what what this will print hopefully over
and over again until because it's in a
while running loop until we actually
terminate the application it's gonna
print running over and over again when
we hit the debug button so there's a few
ways of actually running the program in
Eclipse there's the debug button and
then there's the run button now use the
debug button there's honestly not much
difference between the two but debug
actually lets you I guess make changes
and save your code live and if it's in a
loop you know if it's constantly
checking that code over and over again
like it is in this case it will update
so let's just hit the the debug button
we'll see what happens
right so there we go you can see that we
get a nice window that is the resolution
of our game
it's 16:9 aspect ratio it's got the
title of rain and you can see over here
in the console view where I'm what
constantly as you can see it's
constantly displaying this text called
running
so yeah there's our window next episode
I don't know what we'll do next episode
next episode we're basically gonna just
actually fill it with graphics so that
we can um you know make the background
black and actually start uh start
painting I guess stuff onto our canvas
so we'll start rendering stuff onto the
screen so yeah hope you enjoyed this
tutorial if you did please um please hit
the like button and I'll see you guys
see you guys next time see you guys
tomorrow bye
[Music]
you
[Music]